so John Steele Gordon was educated at
Millbrook school and Vanderbilt
University his articles have appeared in
numerous publications including Forbes
National Review commentary the New York
Times and The Wall Street Journal he's a
contributing editor at American heritage
where he wrote the business of America
column for many years and is currently
writing the Longview column he's the
author of several books including
Hamilton's blessing the extraordinary
life and times of our national debt the
great game the emergence of Wall Street
is a world power and an empire of wealth
the epic history of American economic
power ladies and gentlemen please join
me in welcoming mr. John Steele Gordon
good evening I'm I'm very glad to be
back at Hillsdale College once again
after all it's not only a distinguished
academic institution but I've just
learned that the federal government
doesn't seem to know you exist which
which I think may not be a totally
unalloyed blessing I'm here tonight to
talk about money in American history
it's a long history and a distinctly
chequered one and like all good stories
it has a few heroes such as Alexander
Hamilton and JP Morgan and a few
villains especially Thomas Jefferson
whose malignant hatred of Commerce in
the marketplace in general and banking
in particular transmitted down through
the political generations has visited
disaster after disaster on the American
monetary system by the time the United
States was founded in 1776 coins had
been money for almost 2,500 years
negotiable banknotes had been in general
use for less than a century but by the
last decades of the 18th century a
modern money supply had to have both and
thus we can't talk about the history of
American money without talking about the
history of American banking for bank
notes put banks in the money business
banks store money and they loan it but
most importantly they create it with
bank notes they created it by printing
it today they create money by crediting
your account with a given sum or loaning
you money on a credit card every time
you charge something on a credit card
you are via your bank borrowing and thus
creating money but because banks are in
the money business that makes banking a
very peculiar business indeed cash on
hand for instance is an asset in most
enterprises it is usually a liability
for a bank
because it is owed to the depositors
loans on the other hand are assets
because they are owed to the bank
further if the ordinary business goes
broke it is a financial problem for the
owners the employees and the creditors
but the corporate assets such as
factories will move to stronger hands
and continue to produce but because
banks create money far in excess of
their reserves when a bank goes broke it
can affect the personal economic
well-being of nearly everyone in the
community and even if the bank is large
enough the entire country
that's why banks need very careful
supervision banks after all are owned
and run by human beings and when humans
have in their hands the awesome power to
create money out of thin air the
temptation to abuse that power and
create too much will be given in too
regularly any of you who have ever maxed
out a credit card know that temptation
but banks have often not gotten proper
supervision over the last two hundred
and thirty years of American history and
as a result bank failure has been as
American as apple pie at huge cost to
the American economy the first bank
failure took place in Rhode Island in
1809 when a fraudulent bank capitalized
at $45 issued $800,000 in bank notes a
sum equal to more than 17 thousand times
the resources behind it the failure of
Lehman Brothers in 2008 marked the
beginning of the explosive phase of the
so-called Great Recession that lingers
on to this day when the United States
achieved its independence from Great
Britain in 1783 it lacked a reliable
form of money Britain had forget
forbidden the export of British coins so
while American colonists usually kept
their accounts in pounds shillings and
pence
what circulated in day-to-day
transactions was a hodgepodge of Spanish
French Portuguese and some British coins
as
warehouse certificates for tobacco and
other products since the British had
also forbidden the creation of banks
paper money was printed by some colonies
until the British government forbade
that - Benjamin Franklin while printing
money for the province of Pennsylvania
came up with several characteristically
clever ante counterfeiting techniques in
New York province and elsewhere wampum
the form of money used by the Indians
was used in general commerce as well at
least until the 1760s when a man in New
Jersey invented a wampum counterfeiting
machine and destroyed the value of the
real stuff clever these Americans
lacking a banking system and a regular
money supply the Continental Congress
had no choice but to pay for much of the
revolution by issuing fiat money
so-called Continentals fiat money is
money because the government says it is
money now if the marketplace disagrees
and it often does the fiat money will
quickly inflate into worthlessness
if issued in large quantities that is
what happened to Continentals and the
phrase not worth a continental was in
the American lexicon for over a hundred
years after the Revolution the need to
design and then create a national money
system was urgent task of the new nation
the question of what new unit of account
to adopt was a complex one because the
inhabitants of the various colonies had
used so many different often in
commensurate units Robert Morris whose
financial leisure the MA had done so
much to keep the revolution financially
afloat tried to bridge the difference by
finding the lowest common divisor of the
monetary units most often encountered in
each state he calculated this to be one
thousand four hundred and fortieth of a
Spanish dollar he proposed that this
unit be multiplied by a thousand which
would have made the new American
monetary unit equal to twenty five
thirty sixth of a Spanish dollar
Thomas Jefferson with one of his two
good ideas about money argued instead
for just adopting the dollar as the
monetary unit the origin of the word
dollar lies in the German word for
valley tall in the fifteenth century
major silver deposits were discovered in
what is now the Czech Republic in 1519
the owner of these mines the growths
apostle when Vice kirkin began minting
coins from this silver coins which
weighed a saxon ounce which is slightly
less than our ounce
honest and pure these coins called
hollers literally from the valley had
great acceptance in the marketplace and
were imitated by other german rulers in
english taller soon turned into dollar
just as tall at earlier turned into del
and dale i bet you didn't know that
Hillsdale and the dollar are
etymologically related the holy roman
emperor charles v whose vast dominions
as king of spain included the new silver
mines of Mexico and Peru began to mint
similar coins
thanks to those silver mines the Spanish
dollar became the dominant international
currency of its day
once the dollar was chosen as the
monetary unit it would have been natural
to adopt the clunky British system of
dividing the basic unit into 20 smaller
units called shillings and those into
twelve still smaller units called pence
but the Spanish dollars in use in the
colonies had often been cut into halves
fourths and eights called bits to make
small change which is why the Spanish
dollar was often called pieces of eight
and a quarter is still sometimes
referred to as two bits so an octal
system of currency would have been a
natural idea as well Jefferson however
then had his second and last good idea
about money making smaller units decimal
fractions of the dollar rather than
eighths
Jefferson push for coinage of a
half-dollar
a tenth through which he actually coined
the word dime a twentieth and a
hundredth of the dollar which he called
a cent a word that had already been
coined by Robert Morris Congress however
while adopting the cent five cent dime
and 50 cent coins advocated by Jefferson
decided to authorize a quarter dollar
coin rather than a 20 cent one the
quarter of course is with us yet now the
last distant echo of the old octal
monetary system of colonial days since
the new york stock exchange stopped
trading in eighths of a dollar in 1999
Thomas Jefferson's bright idea for a
decimal coinage began to spread around
the world as bright ideas always do
today every country on Earth has a
decimal currency system even the British
finally adopted one in 1971 now of
course at that time the United States
had very little precious metal from
which to mint coins and therefore it
meant it very few of them it was a
desperate post-revolutionary financial
crisis that helped bring about the
Constitutional Convention of 1787 and
rationalizing the new government's
finances was the first order of business
when it came into being in 1789 that's
why the Department of the Treasury had
40 employees and the Department of State
only five when Robert Morris turned down
the post of secretary of the Treasury in
order to speculate in land a bad idea he
ended up in debtors prison President
Washington offered the post to Alexander
Hamilton who was only in his early 30s
Hamilton faced a formidable task and he
accomplished it brilliantly using a bit
of political sausage-making to push his
plan through despite opposition from
Jefferson and James Madison in return
for the acceptance of Jefferson and
Madison of Hamilton's debt refunding
bill Hamilton agreed to the national
capital being moved out of New York City
and being established on the Potomac
River in 1789 American bonds had been
unmarketable by 1794 the United States
had a good credit rating and its bonds
were selling at a premium in Europe
tally wrong later the French Foreign
Minister but then in the United States
to escape the terror explained why the
United States bonds he said were quote
safe and free from reverses they have
been funded in such a sound manner and
the prosperity of this country is
growing so rapidly that there can be no
doubt of their solvency by 1801
Europeans held 33 million dollars worth
of American securities and European
capital was helping mightily to build
the American economy these sound bonds
were an important part of bank reserves
upon which bank notes could be issued
and they were a convenient means of
transferring large sums of money but
while Hamilton's plan for the national
debt was accepted by Jefferson
Hamilton's idea for a banking system was
subjected to intense opposition from
Jefferson and his allies Hamilton wanted
to create a central bank modeled after
the Bank of England to be called the
Bank of the United States the government
would hold 20% of the shares private
investors the other 80% now a central
bank acts as a depository for government
funds and a means of transferring them
in one part of the country to another no
small consideration in Hamilton's day it
is also a source of loans to the
government and to other banks and it
regulates the money supply keeping its
value steady Hamilton saw it as an
instrument of fiscal efficiency economic
regulation and sound money creation
Jefferson saw it as another giveaway to
the rich as he expected the bank to be
very profitable and it was central banks
always are in 2014 the Federal Reserve
made a profit of 98 billion dollars
which went to the Treasury Jefferson
also saw it as a potential instrument of
tyranny Hamilton did not like the idea
of the government itself issuing paper
money
because he thought that governments
could not be trusted to exert
self-discipline allow government to
print money through Hamilton and they
will print it to solve fiscal problems
rather than using less politically
palatable choices such as raising taxes
or cutting spending
Hamilton thought that an independent
central bank with its shareholders
capital at risk could supply not only a
medium of exchange but the discipline
needed to keep the money sound these
bank notes would circulate at par and
relieve the desperate shortage of cash
further because the central bank could
refuse the notes of state banks that got
out of line that act would mean that no
one else would take them either it was
applied discipline to the whole banking
system Jefferson argued that because the
Constitution does not specifically
empower the government to charter a bank
the government could not do so
this doctrine later became known as
strict construction Hamilton argued for
a doctrine of implied powers to convince
President Washington to sign the bill
Hamilton wrote an essay explaining and
constitutionally justifying his plan he
apparently wrote it in a single night
all 15,000 words of it and remember that
Hamilton wrote with a quill pen not a
computer in it he argued that if the
government was to deal successfully with
its enumerated powers it must be supreme
in deciding how to do so President
Washington his doubts quieted signed the
bill chartering the Bank of the United
States for 20 years again Hamilton's
plan for an American banking system
worked brilliantly there were only three
state banks in 1790 by 1800 they were 29
and by 1811 250 bank failure was
extremely rare in these years
no wonder Daniel Webster was typical
grandiloquence would later say of
Hamilton that quote the whole country
received was delight and the world
with admiration he smoked the rock of
the natural national resources and
abundant streams gushed forth
he touched the dead corpse of the public
credit and it sprung to its feet the
fabled birth of Minerva from the brain
of Jove was hardly more sudden or more
perfect than the financial system of the
United States as it bursts forth from
the conception of Alexander Hamilton
Jefferson did his very best to destroy
it
and while Jefferson had lost the battle
over establishing the Bank of the United
States he won the war in 1811 when the
charter of the Bank came up for renewal
James Madison was president unlike
Jefferson who was an ideologue to his
fingertips Madison was capable of
learning from real world experience and
he having seen how effective the bank
had been now favored renewing the bank's
charter that Madison was
constitutionally over scrupulous and
would not use executive pressure to get
Congress to renew it he simply submitted
the bill and waited for Congress to
decide when his vice-president George
Clinton broke a tie in the Senate by
voting against the bank probably the
only independent political act by a vice
president in American history
the bank died Congress then having
destroyed the government's prime means
of borrowing money soon declared war on
Great Britain the only country on earth
capable of attacking the United States
it then adjourned without making any
provision to pay for the war it was
probably the most feckless act in the
history of the United States Congress a
title for which there is no shortage of
candidates we very nearly lost the war
by simply running out of money to pay
for it but managed to escape with a draw
chastised Congress chartered a second
bank of the United States in 1816 but
had never had the power the first bank
had had banking discipline began to fray
state bank banking laws varied
lately some had good bank regulatory
systems and some had very poor ones some
following Jefferson get banks small by
forbidding branching the small banks are
inherently weak banks dependent on local
economies Andrew Jackson a thoroughgoing
Jeffersonian when it came to money in
banking vetoed the renewal of the second
bank's charter in 1832 until 1913 the
United States would be the only major
country in the world without a central
bank one result was a very high
amplitude of American the American
business cycle with bigger booms and
bigger busts than other countries with
discipline much loosened by the decline
and fall of central banking in the
United States banks and bad banking
proliferated as did bank failure by 1840
there were a thousand banks in operation
in the United States 20 years later the
number had nearly doubled but almost
half the banks founded between 1810 and
1820 failed before 1825 a similar
percentage of those founded in the 1830s
failed before 1845 in the 73 years
between the adoption of the Constitution
and the outbreak of the Civil War the
money supply multiplied no less than 40
times from 15 million to 600 million
only 25 percent of this money supply
however was in the form of gold and
silver the rest was in demand deposits
and banknotes with most of these
thousands of banks issuing bank notes
knowing which ones were good and which
ones were not was a huge problem even
though most only circulated locally the
notes could only be redeemed for species
gold and silver at the bank's
headquarters and some banks came to be
called Wildcat banks as their
headquarters were quite deliberately out
among the wild cats and hard to find
publishers issued what were called bank
note detectors to help identify which
notes were good which dubious and which
were known to be fraudulent
it was monetary chaos
but just like the prospect of being
hanged in a fortnight great Wars
concentrate minds wonderfully and the
American Civil War was the greatest war
fought in the Western world in the
hundred years between the fall of
Napoleon and the outbreak of World War
one the fiscal demands of the Civil War
were enormous with the national debt
soaring from 65 million to 2.7 billion
in 1865 the United States government
became the first government in history
to spend a billion years in a single
year it wouldn't spend a billion years
again until 1917 the federal government
quickly began issuing fiat money so
called greenbacks amounting to four
hundred and fifty million dollars by the
war's end about eleven percent of total
federal outlays while people were forced
to accept them in payment of debt for
they were declared legal tender the
government itself would not accept them
in payment of taxes which had to be paid
in gold but while these greenbacks whose
value in gold fluctuated with the
fortunes of the Union Army caused
considerable inflation roughly seventy
five percent by the war's end it was
nowhere near as bad as in the
Confederacy with a much smaller ability
to raise money through bond issues and
taxes the Confederacy was forced to
issue about a billion and a half dollars
in fiat money to pay its bills southern
states and cities also issued paper
money and because the south had limited
facilities for both paper making and
printing counterfeiters had a field day
Gresham's law that bad money drives out
good immediately kicked in and gold and
silver coins disappeared into mattresses
as people spent the fiat money and of
course inflation took off the South
suffered an inflation of about seven
hundred percent in just the first two
years of the war why the wars and
Confederate money had become worth
and the southern economy was in shambles
it would take a century to recover to
help finance the war Congress also
finally tackled the chaotic American
banking system in 1863 it established a
system of nationally chartered banks
these banks had to have at least $50,000
in capital a large sum at the time and
had to hold 60% of that capital in the
United States Treasury securities
national banks were subject to rigorous
oversight by the new controller of the
currency by such means as a sudden
unannounced audits these banks were
allowed to issue banknotes but only
using a uniform design supplied by the
government and the notes had to be
backed 100% by pledged Treasury bonds
the federal government thought that most
state banks would take national charters
but they didn't as many could not meet
the capital requirements by the end of
1863 there were 134 national banks
almost all of them new banks changes in
the law in 1864 sped conversions but
still most banks remained state
chartered so in March 1865 Congress
imposed a 10% tax on the face value of
state bank issued banknotes driving
those banks out of the banknote business
it also caused many of them to take
national charters by 1866 there were
1600 national banks only about 200 state
banks left in existence there were also
of course mutual savings banks private
banks Savings and Loan associations and
credit unions none of them issued
banknotes but all acted as banks taking
deposits and making loans and each type
was regulated separately this
multiplicity of bank regulation unknown
in any other country would be the source
of disaster in its 20th century more
than once because of the Jeffersonian
hatred for big banks national banks were
forbidden until 1922 to have branches or
operate across state lines
so their number grew quickly as the
country's economy and population
exploded in size after the civil war
meanwhile state banks discovered that
while they could no longer print
banknotes they could still create money
by simply crediting a borrower's balance
in a checking account their number also
began to grow quickly by 1900 there were
3731 national banks and 4405 state banks
by 1920 there were about 30,000 banks in
the United States more than all the rest
of the world put together and almost all
of them were single unit banks depended
on the prosperity of just the local
community but at least the era of
Wildcat banking was at an end by the end
of the Civil War there were only three
types of paper money in the country
national bank notes backed by bank
reserves United States notes the old
greenbacks redeemable in gold beginning
in 1879 and silver certificates that
could be redeemed in silver the country
was back on the gold standard now the
gold standard simply means that a
country establishes the value of its
currency in gold and stands ready to buy
or sell unlimited quality quantities of
it at that price in the early 18th
century
the value of the British Pound had been
set at 3 pounds 17 shillings ten and a
half pence per troy ounce of gold by Sir
Isaac Newton of all people enjoying the
perks of a largely no show but very well
remunerated job as master of the kings
mint in 1821 after the Napoleonic Wars
the Bank of England went on the gold
standard many other major countries
followed the value of the dollar was set
at 20 dollars and 66 cents per ounce of
gold
now while the gold standard was popular
with the wealthy especially in the
industrialised northeast for it
effectively makes inflation impossible
and facilitates overseas trade the less
affluent hated it
most Americans in the late 19th century
were still farmers
farmers are chronic debtors like all
debtors they liked inflation as it made
it possible to pay back debt their debts
in Cheaper money faced with a strong
demand by one influential group bankers
and industrialists for a gold standard
and an equally strong demand for an
inflationary monetary policy by another
influential group farmers the government
as so often happens in a democracy tried
to have it both ways for a while it even
worked while returning to the gold
standard Congress passed the bland
Allison act in 1878 requiring the
Treasury to buy between 2 million and
four million dollars in silver every
month and turned it into coin or silver
certificates at the ratio of 16 to 1 in
other words 16 ounces of silver were
declared by congressional Fiat to be
worth one ounce of gold at the time that
was about the market price but as ever
more silver poured out of Western mines
in the 1880s Nevada and Colorado alone
accounted for fully 40% of world's
silver production the price declined to
about 20 to 1 by 1890 that year Congress
ordered the Treasury to buy point 4.5
million ounces of silver a month and
turn it into coin or silver certificates
at the 16 to 1 ratio
a sure recipe for inflation with its
silver policy greatly increasing the
money supply and the gold standard
keeping the value of the dollar steady
the government managed in effect boasted
guarantee and to forbid inflation as
anyone who has taken an introductory
economics course could predict Gresham's
law kicked in silver worth 1 xx the
price of gold in the market was declared
to be worth 1/16 the price of gold when
kind as money so naturally people began
to spend the silver and hoard the gold
and the gold started trickling out of
the Treasury with the major depression
that began in 1893 that trickle turned
into a flood soon the Treasury's gold
supply was getting dangerously low and
Congress
used to authorize another bond issue to
replenishing JP Morgan thoroughly
alarmed took the train to Washington to
see President Cleveland but the
president refused to see him knowing
that Wall Street then as now was the
less favorite whipping boy and JP Morgan
was the very embodiment of Wall Street I
have come down to see the president
Morgan said in his best Imperial manner
and I am going to stay until I see him
with the situation rapidly deteriorating
Cleveland saw him the next morning
Morgan's lawyers had dug up an obscure
civil war-era law allowing the
government to issue bonds to buy coin
without congressional authorization
Morgan offered that he and August
Belmont jr. who represented the
Rothschilds would buy 100 million
dollars in gold coin in Europe and give
it to the Treasury in exchange for the
new bonds further he promised to keep
the market steady and prevent the gold
from leaching out of the Treasury once
again he was in effect offering to act
as a central bank insulating the
Treasury from market forces and it
worked the next year the depression
began to lift but William Jennings Bryan
swept to the presidential nomination of
the Democratic Party by promising to
prevent mankind from being crucified
upon a cross of gold he lost the
election badly the William McKinley
whose slogan was sound money protection
and prosperity in 1907 Morgan again
acted as a central bank to deal with the
financial panic of that year even
Jeffersonians Jefferson's heirs began to
realize that a central bank was now a
necessity
after all JP Morgan over 70 at that
point would not be around forever
in 1913 ironically the year that Morgan
died the Federal Reserve System was
created but while Wall Street had wanted
a single bank located in New York after
all that's where the money is 12 banks
were created in cities across the
country again the Jeffersonian dread of
Powell
Banks was at work in a banking panic
member banks could maintain liquidity by
borrowing from the Fed as it is nowadays
often called using their loan portfolios
as security national banks were required
to join and so could state banks that
could meet the requirements but most
could not meet them thus the very banks
that most needed the ability to borrow
from the Federal Reserve in an emergency
couldn't do so as rural areas of the
country began to go into recession in
the middle of the 1920s thanks to
falling food prices the banks that
served small-town America began to fail
by the late 1920s these failures were
averaging about 500 a year and when the
Great Depression began in 1929 the
number of bank failures exploded while
the money supply contracted sharply
there were about one-third deflation
between 1929 and 1933 greatly
exacerbating the depression by the fall
of 1932 bank runs where panic depositors
suddenly withdraw their funds fearing
failure and thus making that failure a
self-fulfilling prophecy began to spread
from individual banks to the banking
system as a whole
by the time Franklin Roosevelt was
inaugurated on March 4th 1933 state
governors had closed the banks in 38
states and the other ten have limited
withdrawals the American banking system
and thus its money supply was near death
Roosevelt closed all the banks and gave
his first fireside chat explaining what
the government had done and assuring the
public that when a bank reopens it was
because the government had found it to
be sound and therefore it was a safer
place for one's money than the mastress
the public believed him and money began
to flow once more into banks it had been
a very near run thing the Federal
Reserve was reorganized Deposit
Insurance ended bank runs and federal
reserve issued banknotes became the
dominant form
of paper money as national banks stopped
issuing them gold coins were withdrawn
from circulation and it became illegal
to hold met the medal in bullion form
the system steadied in 1951 a man named
William Boyle who worked for the
Franklin National Bank in Long Island
invented the credit card an idea that
quickly spread spread [ __ ] creating
the first new form of money since the
banknote in the 1960s the price of
silver rising the United States stopped
minting silver coins making some
so-called sandwich coins instead
thus technically they were not coins at
all but tokens nevertheless now a
trivial portion of the money supply they
continued to be accepted and therefore
were money Gresham's law however kicked
in as it usually does and the old silver
coins quickly disappeared from
circulation in 1971 President Nixon
severed the last link between American
money and precious metals when he was no
longer when he no longer allowed foreign
central banks to redeem dollars for gold
the United States now had nothing but
fiat money so why didn't it inflate into
worthlessness as fiat money has so often
done in the past
one reason that was that most of the
money supply was now in the form of
demand deposits not notes or coins money
have largely become electronic blips in
the bowels of vast and interconnected
computer systems the second was that an
international currency market had sprung
up trading trillions of dollars in
currency a day if the market thought a
country was pursuing unwise monetary
policies it could devalue that country's
currency with startling speed France
found that out in 1980 when newly
elected president Francois Mathurin
nationalized the French banking system
and tried to move the country toward
socialism the rapidly sinking value of
the franc forced him into a hasty
retreat today coins are surely on the
way to extinct
after 2700 years it now costs the
government two cents to mint a penny
most of which end up in coffee cans in
bedroom closets and banknotes are
quickly declining as plastic becomes
ubiquitous even prostitutes I'm reliably
informed now happily accept plastic in
payment for their services the Internal
Revenue Service would of course love to
eliminate cash all together to prevent
tax cheating drug dealers and waiters
are less enthusiastic about that soon
and I'm sure you won't even have to use
plastic as you make your way through a
checkout line the iPhone in your pocket
will sync to the store computer download
a receipt and you're on your way it will
indeed be a brave new world one Thomas
Jefferson could not have dreamed of and
would surely have hated I doubt
Alexander could have Hamilton could have
conceived of it either but I bet he
would have loved it thank you very much
Thank You mr. Gordon we now have time
for a few questions when the microphone
comes to you please stand
do you have views about money created by
alternatives that getting away from
government monopolies such as maybe
Bitcoin well bitcoins to the extent that
I understand them are a sort of
electronic version of scrip scrip was
paper money printed by private
organisations and used locally often it
was companies would pay their workers in
in scrip and then the the workers would
have to buy their goods at the company
store and guess what always high prices
I mean so scrip has often been abused
and I really I'm not quite sure what
bitcoins are yet I don't know that
economists know either so we're gonna
have to wait and see what bitcoins turn
into but basically you know the money
supply is now banks and private
organisations can't regulate banks only
the government can regulate banks they
just unfortunately they often do it very
badly
what do you think about what mr.
Bernanke has done over the last few
years with regard to the American debt
and to the absorption of it by the Fed
well he's he's writing the back of a
tiger I mean at some point those has got
to get off the the Fed's balance sheet
and that's going to be very tricky to do
I hope that Janet Yellen will this month
begin to raise interest rates a bit but
then you know if interest rates go back
to normal the service on the debt is
gonna go through the roof and that's
gonna crowd out other federal spending
or they'll raise taxes or they'll borrow
the money to pay the interest on the
debt which is really lousy idea so I'm
not a great fan of Ben Bernanke he was
in a very difficult position the whole
time I would first thing I wish he had
done it was not let Lehman Brothers go
broke I think that was he said he didn't
have the authority you know do it and
find that the authority later Franklin
Roosevelt closed all the banks in 1933
on the authority of the trading with the
enemy Act from 1917 and you know a week
later they passed legislation to
thoroughly authorize him to do it
sometimes you have to act quickly and
clean the mess up later and I think that
he was a terrible mistake to let Lehman
Brothers go down not that layman
Brothers didn't deserve a severe
whipping because they certainly did
as you mentioned we are turning from
using cash to solely cards and even
iPhones what are your views on Americans
being the leaders and overspending and
relying on credit to live I'm sorry I
can't I can hear you but I can't quite
understand how as you mentioned we are
turning from using cash to solely cards
and even iPhones what are your views on
Americans being the leaders in
overspending and relying on credit to
live well been overspending almost by
definition is a bad idea
I mean sometimes you have to do it we
certainly you know with many times we
overspent I mean the National Hamilton
said the national debt of it is not
excessive will be to us a national
blessing and it is certainly has been a
national blessing many times we used it
to save the Union in the 1860s we use it
to save the American economy in the
1930s we used it to save the world
in the 1940s but in 1970 the national
debt was around three hundred billion
dollars which was about 39 percent of
GDP today 45 years later it's a hundred
and four percent of GDP and eighteen
point five trillion dollars and why
since 1970 we have had no great Wars
remotely resembling World War two we
have had no Great Depression remotely
resembling the 1930s and we've had
decades of enormous prosperity in the
80s and 90s in the early part of the
2000s so why did we run up this enormous
debt the reason is so that nobody in
Washington DC ever had to say no to
anybody and what we are doing is we are
stealing this money from our
grandchildren so that we can live better
today
you know because today's debt is
tomorrow's taxes there's no escape from
that and so I you know is it is American
democracy at its absolute worst
what what do you think about going back
to the gold standard we can't go back to
the 19th century gold standard because
there simply isn't enough gold I mean
there's very little you know gold is
very very rare stuff you all the gold
ever mined in the world would make a
cube about 21 feet on a side yeah would
easily fit in this room it would be
pretty heavy and so I just gold standard
is too inflexible I think that Steve
Forbes his idea of using gold as a proxy
for other values is a good one that the
the Federal Reserve should try to keep
the price of gold
steady rather than just ignore it like
they do now we can't go back to the
literal gold standard where you could
literally you know if you go into the
Treasury Building from Pennsylvania
Avenue the first room you come to is
called the cash room and used to be you
could take silver certificates or gold
back dollar bills as they recall they
were backed by gold you could take that
into the cash room and they would give
you the medal for it you know the old
silver certificates would say this
certifies that there is on demand
certified in the Treasury of the United
States $1.00 in silver payable to bearer
on demand and literally true as a minor
tourist event to go into the Treasury
and say give him a silver certificate
they would solemnly hand you a silver
dollar that's just not possible anymore
so go back to the you know the classic
gold standard is a well it's just it
wouldn't work I mean it's a nice idea in
theory I suppose but unless somebody
discovers a really big gold mine and
that's highly unlikely at this point
there are a number of people somewhat
influential and learned that believe
that no way can United States tax itself
out of the large debt that we have
however the International Monetary Fund
has recommended
United States exercises a bail-in would
you have any comments and perhaps
explains to some of the folks what a
bale in is a bale I'm not quite sure
what a Bailey is I mean it's somebody
put up your bail a bit about veil is
done in Cyprus it was done in Hungary oh
and it's recommended by the
International Monetary Fund - the only
thing that can save our debt and what a
Balaam is is that the banks have the
authority through the government the
United States government - particularly
over a weekend go in and reduce every
American's financial accounts brokerage
or banks by a percentage like say 10% so
that money goes to reduce the debt and
everybody wakes up on Monday morning
with lower national debt but lower
assets if you want to start a rebellion
in this country again I just try that
one I think that you know in 1945 the
national debt was one hundred and thirty
percent of GDP in 1970 it was thirty
nine percent of GDP now how did we do
that well very simple we didn't borrow
more money or very little money like 16
billion over those 25 years and the
American economy grew enormous Lee in
those 25 years we can do the same that
we did in the 1990s when the G when the
debt as a percentage of GDP went down
and down and down for those you know
after the Republicans took control of
Congress in 1994 if we just stopped
borrowing money you know tell somebody
no sorry we can't afford it and then the
American economy would grow us out of
the debt we're never going to pay back
the debt we did once in 1835 the only
country only major country in the world
ever to pay off its national debt didn't
last long because we went in the deep
depression in 1837
but now when
going into everybody's bank balance and
helping themselves at ten percent and I
it would not be pretty on Monday morning
I promise you thank you very much so
obviously an interesting facet of money
in American history is government aided
government funded education so I guess
my question is what is your opinion on a
government supplying aid to students
seeking higher education well the first
thing is that if you have a commodity
that keeps rising in price over and
above inflation for year after year and
there is no constraint on supply you
have a cartel in operation and that is
what higher education in this country is
it is a cartel and the cartel mechanism
is the accrediting organizations and the
government student loans and stuff
simply exacerbate that problem I mean
they help the students go to school and
the schools immediately raise their
prices to absorb that new money what
they need to do is compete and we need
to thoroughly reform the accrediting
organizations because they are at the
heart of this beast I mean I went when I
graduated from Vanderbilt it was eleven
hundred dollars a semester twenty-two
hundred a year take out the inflation
that's roughly fifteen thousand tuition
and fees today at Vanderbilt or sixty
thousand in other words of course four
times as much as it cost me to go to
that school Oh are they really getting
four times as good in education I kind
of doubt it they get much better dorms
and they have wonderful facilities and
all that sort of stuff um but they're
not getting a better basic education
they're just paying a lot more for it
the Fed has put this interest rate hike
on hold for a few months now when do you
think action will take place and how do
you think the market will react to it
well an awful lot of people now think
it's going to happen in the December
meeting of the Open Market Committee and
I suspect it will happen the Fed never
likes to do anything it doesn't have to
do because whatever they do they're
going to get yelled at and so it's
easier to do nothing but as I said at
some point we're going to have to begin
to reduce that stuff on the balance
sheet and raise interest rates back up
to normal and I hope they start doing it
sooner rather than later
the market went down a hundred 80 points
today because people think they're going
to raise it in December but a hundred
eighty points is no big deal today so I
hope she starts in in December but we
will say I thought she was gonna do it
in November but um or in actually in
October I thought she was going to do it
but I was wrong as usual thank you for
your speech dr. Calvert in the first
lecture in the CCA had said at the end
of his at the end of his lecture that
we'll never live in a cashless society
because humans having a particular
affinity to a physical exchange of goods
how would you met how would you respond
to that statement well I talked to dr.
Calvert about it actually and we just
have a disagreement about the future um
which nice thing about disagreements
about the future is neither of us as
long at least for now and so I I just
can't imagine we're going to have coins
jingling in our pocket for much longer I
mean I think banknotes will last for a
lot longer because of various reasons I
mean drug deals and things like that if
you really want to break the heart of
Russian oligarchs and change the
hundred-dollar bill and to clear the old
ones not good delivery anymore but I
just I can't see that in a hundred years
yeah when we're flying around in our
personal Jetson what have you if they
were still going to be using dollar
bills but we will see
or you will say I probably won't I
apologize if I'm misinformed but at the
beginning of the school year I heard an
awful lot about China starting to create
a new system of money that they hoped
would become the main source of exchange
internationally if you know anything
about that do you know if that poses any
threat to the American dollar at all I
don't think so in the short term I mean
for one thing there's no economy in the
world big enough other than the United
States to really act as the reserve
currency there are other reserve
currencies but if the dollar is the one
that counts and the yuan is or they
remember I never have figured out why
they have two different names is you
know at the moment there people don't
trust China and for a very good reason
and why would anybody keep the currency
of China as a reserve currency when
China could act tomorrow to change its
value so I just think it's gonna be a
long time before that happens China
would love to have that happen but I
China has got really big problems that
we don't hear much about because it's so
hard to report in China and their
statistics aren't worth much because
underlings tend to tell the big guys
what they want to hear so they don't
find themselves you know cleaning
latrines and in Seiki airing so I think
you know China's I think China in the
next 25 years is going to be a source of
really big news and a lot of it's going
to be unpleasant but again we will say
if the interest rate were to be set by
market conditions today at what rate do
you see that percentage being oh well
I'm not about to predict interest rate
I mean Wall Street tries it all the time
and doesn't do very good job of it so I
have no idea what the market would set
in a purely free market what the
interest rates would be I have no way of
knowing that I wish I did I could make a
lot of money I don't mean to ask it an
appropriate question but if you can
comment what do you think of mr. Trump's
economic comments or positions or
theories do you have anything you care
to say I'm sorry say that again do you
have any comment that you would care to
make about Donald Trump's economic
pronouncements well Donald Trump is a
very entertaining man god save us from
winning the White House as I said at
dinner I said I just really cannot
conceive that having a president who
colors his hair being male and so when
I'll leave it at that I mean Donald
Trump is having a very good time but
he's a distraction and I suspect because
he has an awful tendency to shoot his
mouth off and I think one of these days
he's gonna say something that he can't
take back and people will not forgive
and then he'll just fade like a pop the
balloon I sincerely hope that's the case
hello first let me thank you for
speeding sign was very illuminating for
someone like me who has always been had
a close affinity towards Thomas
Jefferson first let me say that you
brought on your speech originally
talking about fiat currency being
instilled with in the Revolutionary era
and how that was a positive aspect and
then later on went on to say about how
the fiat currency that was used during
the Civil War from the South was
disparaging and I would just be very
curious to see how those two interplay
within your mind
thank you well in both cases with the
Continentals in the American Revolution
and the Fiat money in the South in the
in the Civil War they had no alternative
it was that or lose the war and again
they will figure out the consequences
later most Confederate money said that
it would be redeemed in gold two years
after the signing of peace between the
United States and the Confederacy you
know that fiat money is never a good
idea at least back in those days it was
never a good idea but if it's the only
only means of staying alive there was a
New York real estate man named William
Zeckendorf who died in 1976 and
Manhattan real estate is a game of very
high stakes and he made a great deal of
money at it
but he was famous for borrowing at high
rates and somebody asked him why and he
said because it's better to be alive at
20% than dead at the prime rate he died
in 1976 in 1980 the prime rate actually
hit 20% so have yo
necessity makes us do things we have to
do and so that's we borrowed money you
know we printed the stuff in the 1770s
and the Confederacy printed in the 1860
in the same vein I came to America in
1968 I went to the ground round to
Pawtucket Rhode Island to have my first
Manhattan seventy-five cents
I put 750 in a drawer I said once a
rainy day comes and I feel down I will
have 10 Manhattan's last year that
happened I went to the same place put by
750 on the bar and I called one
Manhattan who in heaven's name drank the
other nine
I don't know um okay I I can tell you a
story of my grandfather who was he went
to Wall Street in 1898 as a runner which
was messenger boy and he was paid $5.00
a week and he would for lunch he would
go into a bar and he would buy a beer
for a nickel and he'd never liked beer
and so he would give the beer to the
thirstiest person he could see and but
that nickel entitled him to to the free
lunch some so prices have changed a bit
you all say it was a roommate with
Douglas Fairbanks later became the
famous movie actor and I actually have a
letter from Douglas Fairbanks asking my
grandfather to be patient about that ten
dollar loan I don't know if he ever did
pay it back thank you very much